[Music]
ethical hacking find exploits in your
web application before the bad guys do
as a web developer there are 10 common
security risks that you'll want to be
aware of things like database injection
broken authentication and cross-site
scripting hackers have been exploiting
these vulnerabilities from day 0.
like back in 05 when cross-site
scripting was used to update your
myspace page with sami is my hero or
just last year when the chinese version
of twitter weibo
exposed over 500 million user accounts
because of a brute force attack on their
authentication system you can reduce
your chances of being a victim by
running penetration tests on your web
application
i refuse to be a victim
and a popular free tool for doing so is
the burp suite whenever you visit a
website the browser automatically makes
requests to a bunch of servers for the
html images in javascript that that site
needs to run
the burp suite is like a man in the
middle that can eavesdrop on or
intercept every single request on its
dashboard we can find the proxy tab
then open an instance of the chromium
browser then visit a website that's
given us permission to run penetration
testing the tool will intercept every
request
allowing us to inspect it and optionally
modify its values before it gets sent to
the server
this is kind of like casing the joint to
find potential requests to exploit for
example you might submit a form to
complete a
shopping cart order if you change the
order amount on the post request and
their server side validation is weak
you may have just received a five finger
discount but in real life hacking is
rarely that simple
it takes a lot of tedious trial and
error luckily you can automate your
bruteforce attacks with the intruder
tool
you might have a bunch of username
password combinations that get added to
a request dynamically
then sent to the server with a variety
of different attack types all you have
to do is click the start attack button
then sit back and wait for a successful
response once you've gained access
you can use those same credentials to
determine if you can maintain access to
extract sensitive data from the target
if you had permission to do this you
wear a white hat if you didn't have
permission but notified the target you
wear a gray hat and if you're selling
the data for dogecoin on the dark web
then you wear
a black hat this has been ethical
hacking on the web in 100 seconds
but stay tuned because today i've
invited bartos from the web security
academy to take us beyond 100 seconds
and level up our skills on web security
hello internet bartos from web security
academy here and i'm super happy that we
partnered with fireship again
several days ago jeff posted a video
about course cross origin risk of
sharing and in today's video
i would like to give you an insight into
why we need course in the first place
we will take a look at same origin
policy which is the fundamental
principle of web security model
we will start with the theory and
explanation of important concepts
followed by coding labs so that you can
see
the mechanics of this policy in practice
let's get started
in order to understand same origin
policy let's first understand the
concept of origin
when you take the triple of scheme
domain port this is what constitutes to
origin
first three examples when we have https
the domain web security academy and here
the port is implicit because when you
use
https the default port for this is four
for free the default port for http
is port 80. so
when you have the same scheme the same
domain and the same port
regardless of the path it is considered
to be the same origin
if you have a different subdomain
or a different port or a different
scheme these are all different origins
why is this so important to
differentiate
those origins let's jump to the next
slide so
the same origin policy creates
some kind of secure context for your
websites
running in the browser so imagine that
you have site a.com
which will consider our origin
a and the browser fetches this website
from the server and then we have origin
b
that is hosted on site b.com
so imagine that you fetch index.html
image jpg script.js
and inside of single tab we have this
secure context with javascript running
dom document object model cookies and
web storage
and if this second origin
is loaded in the different tab they
cannot
communicate each other they are isolated
but
you can still fetch resources
from the different origin for example
you would be able to
load images css styles or scripts
to enrich your website with resources
from the different origin
and here is very important to note that
this is the browser which enforces same
origin policy and as i told you
there's going to be some kind of secure
context that is going to
bind this origin and the execution of
this
website and scripts and everything
related to this website
in your browser and this single
website would not be allowed to
communicate with different origins
so imagine that you load some website
and you would like to communicate
with site b by default same origin
policy restrict this kind of
communication
because who said that they can't trust
each other
maybe one website is evil and we would
like to prevent this kind of
communication
in order for this kind of communication
origin b must white list origin a
explicitly saying that origin a
is trustworthy let's look at this
example we have a simple website which
displays
hello world some image it links to some
style sheets and scripts and also
it has some simple inline scripts
implemented to call
apis on different urls
so to serve this application we have a
simple server
which is written in node.js and utilizes
express.js
library to serve our application
if we look here we see that whenever
there is a request
to this url we are going to serve
index.html whenever there is a request
to
this url we are going to execute some
simulated logic in this case just a
console log and also we have a
second application before we jump into
the second application
let's note that this application is
going to be
served at port 88
and the second application which is
called external because it's going to
simulate our external origin is going to
be served
on the different port and here
it's going to serve some static
resources in the folder
public so we see it serves an image
script
and some stylesheet and also
exposes api method
for http get to also simulate some
logic in this case console.log so let's
also look how we can run those two
applications npm run policies would
start our first application
npm policies external would start our
second application as you remember we
are trying to
see same origin policy in practice
we know that we can fetch external css
and scripts like this so here you see
that
we are requesting our external origin
which we know by the port number here
they were successfully applied image was
successfully loaded
if we go to style we see that the port
is different and everything actually
works fine
we also know that same origin policy
prevents some api executions
so here we have two buttons call api
and call external api let's look at the
console
to see that we have some message here
it says i was fetched from external
origin
this is a script that we can see here
there was no problem in importing a
script
from a different origin our external
origin
and that we see the port is 8081
so let's try to execute api method
on our first origin so
looking back on our index.html
we see whenever we click button call api
it's going to call our server
then get the response and display it in
the console
so whenever i click here console.log
success and also our server says that
api was called
but different situation
would be when we would try to
call external api because now our
api endpoint is living on the different
origin so if we click here we see
two things that happened first of all
a request actually hit the server
because we see
console.log from the server that
external api was called
but actual response was blocked
on the browser because we know that same
origin policy
is enforced on the browser level so now
because we didn't actually allow this
origin to communicate
with our website the result
is blocked to recap we were able to get
style sheets images and scripts to be
executed
on our website but calling external api
was prevented from reading the result
but internal api call was successful
if you liked how it was explained to you
that we start with the theory and follow
with coding labs
i encourage you to check out my web
security fundamentals course that you
can get right now with
a 40 discount using the code that you
see
on the screen right now during this
concise one hour course i will teach you
the most important
aspects of web security model from the
theoretical
and practical perspective so that you
will never ever end up with course error
again
and you would know how to efficiently
prevent cross-site scripting
or at least minimize the risk of
cross-site scripting to a negligible
degree
see you in the course thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one